especially behind white pieces  and he brings on the heath baby  g4 take that baby  says chakri i want to see now the  players faces because that's when you go  like what  what is going on here oh boy  that's why we like shakria that's why we  love him  because he's not shying away from  something that the engine would  immediately frown upon  so it's obviously a mouse slip and he  intended g3  nah i can guarantee you that it's none  of that  but uh nice one danny there nice one i  have to give it to you that that was a  good call that  it's interesting that you know where he  he has he hasn't bothered taking this  paul  he's gone he's gone bishop before check  i mean yeah can we just go back a move  can we just look at nighttime i think i  checked it danny with the engine once  when it came up and i